You know, we all deal
with these things in life.
We deal with difficulties.
We deal with complications.
How do you deal with
the trials and tribulations
of life?
No matter what,
whose fault it is,
you got to take
full ownership.
Whether it's in your career,
whether it's in your family,
whether it's in your relationships,
you need to have
full ownership in your life
and everything you're doing.
That's the only way
you can get full control
of your life and be
that individual you want
to be in the world.
Take accountability,
be responsible,
do your own research.
Yeah.
Vault up with Gauntlet.
Hell yeah. Yeah, yeah.
He didn't pay for that.
That was a soft shill.
Dude, you're the man.